has more in the latest sport to dance
its way into the games
breaking or what you may know as break
dancing
is now an official olympic sport
an 18-year breaking veteran and six-time
footwork champion atn couldn't be more
thrilled i was ecstatic
breaking will make its debut on the
olympic stage in 2024 in paris
which is something atn never thought
he'd see
i had hoped that it would reach this
level but i never thought it actually
would
atn hopes that this level of exposure
will only help the sport grow
expand fans it's going to expand
practitioners
he also hopes this will give outsiders a
chance to actually see the sport for
what it is
there's a lot of people who have a
preconceived notion of what
breaking is but it has gotten to
heights that no one could have ever
imagined with style
and power and the ability to do the
things that we do and these kids do
speaking of those kids the international
olympic committee actually began
pursuing urban events to lure a younger
audience
which atn has also been focused on as he
alongside his
brother and friend kareem who were also
b-boys
started alchemy breaking academy here in
las vegas about a year and a half ago
as a way to teach the next generation
the skills and intricacies of breaking
and there's one student in particular
who not surprisingly
is a natural my son is our star student
and who knows we may just see 11 year
old ropes representing the us
at the olympics i could be a biased
father
but i think my son will definitely be at
the level
to be an olympic champion kevin martin
8 sports now all right thank you very
much kevin they don't want to be called
break dancing it's breaking we'll be
right back